jessica stopped three paces from the
chair dropped a small curtsy a gentle
flick of left hand along the line of her
skirt paul gave the short bow his
dancing master had taught
the one used when in doubt of another
station the nuances of paul's greeting
were not lost on the reverend mother
she said he's a cautious one jessica
jessica's hand went to paul's shoulder
tightened there for heartbeat fear pulls
through her palm that she had herself
under control thus he has been taught
your reverence
critics and readers seem to both agree
frank herbert
is not a very good writer this is the
impression i get when i
read about people talking about dune
when i myself was
interested in doing when i first read
dune and it seemed to me
and something that always put me off
from wanting to read it for a while
was that yeah it's good it's got great
ideas
interesting story but the writing the
prose itself
is subpar and then i read it and to make
this as short as possible i think that
it is not subpar i think that frank
herbert's writing is very good
i've done some analysis some close
reading of the text i'm an english major
so i am i'm qualified to do that i'm
going to try to
boil down frank herbert's writing as
much as you could boil down any writer's
style but try to boil down frank
herbert's writing style
into three main elements an unusual
narrating point of view absolute clarity
of information
and spares but effective descriptive
language
to me a lot of the discussion of his
writing style is very
very vague in a lot of ways people say
well it's clunky it's
awkward it's stilted i want to get into
the actual words on the page and see
what makes frank herbert's writing tick
in chapter 1 of dune there's a short
scene
paul is being tested by the reverend
mother gaius helen
mahiam mohium i'm choosing this scene
because it's early in the book so there
aren't any
spoilers also it was in the trailer with
little timmy chalamet
screaming his heart out the reverend
mother gaius helen mohem
sat in a tapestry chair watching mother
and son approach
windows on each side of her overlooked
the curving southern bend
of the river and the green farmlands of
the atridis family holding but the
reverend mother
ignored the view she was feeling her age
this morning more than a little petulant
she blamed it on space travel and the
association with that abominable spacing
guild in its secretive ways but here was
a mission that required personal
attention from a benny jesuit
with the site even the patasha emperor's
truthsayer couldn't evade that
responsibility when the duty call came
damn that jessica the reverend mother
thought if only she'd born as a girl as
she was ordered to do
the old woman studied paul in one
gestalt and flicker
face oval like jessica's but strong
bones hair
the duke's black black but with brow
line of the maternal grandfather who
cannot be named
in that thin disdainful nose shape of
directly staring green eyes
like the old duke the paternal
grandfather who's dead
three things what exactly happens in
this
short scene dune is written in a an
omniscient style
there are so many different types of
viewpoints you could use in writing you
can have first person viewpoint second
person
you you can have third person which is
extremely common in fiction especially
in fantasy however we usually have third
person limited
in which we are trapped in one
character's viewpoint or in the case of
certain fantasy epics we're jumping to
multiple viewpoints but we're not
jumping around in the same scene it's
separate chapters you know like in the
stormlight archive we have caledon
chapter we're in caledon said we have a
dowel in our chapter where in dalinner's
head
this is not the case in dune let's let
the man himself brandon sanderson tell
us a little bit about
dune's point of view a given paragraph
could be in
any viewpoint at any time and the author
will decide the author is generally not
going to withhold any information from
you dune is the classic sci-fi example
when someone walks on
a stage that's going to betray them you
jump in his head and he's like oh it's
going to suck when i betray these people
right you as the as the reader are being
given all the information and that's
exactly it
in this short scene that's not even a
full page we go from the reverend
mother's viewpoint
to paul's viewpoint back to the reverend
mother back to jessica
back to paul with each paragraph change
we're in a new person's head that can be
a bit disorienting especially when you
first start the book
and i think there are certain advantages
and disadvantages to using the style
advantages are you are getting a huge
amount of information about the world
and characters
at all times if this was written solely
from paul's point of view we would have
a lot of questions not saying it would
be a bad scene but it would just be very
different
because of this true omniscient
viewpoint we are getting
information beyond what would be normal
this is
totally intentional we're getting the
view from 10 000 feet above
but i think the point of the series is
to to see the forces of history
how they affect one another and how
history is constantly
in flux i think that's one of the
benefits of
the the point of view and downside is
yeah it's going to turn people off
you don't have much personal connection
with any one character
you aren't going to have the same kind
of connection you would with someone
where we're just in their point of view
also a certain amounts of suspense are
not there there is suspense of course in
dune a lot of suspense but
it's not in the same way as it would be
if we were only in one character's head
i think
the second element in frank herbert's
style that i want to
get a hold at is this clarity of
information
frank herbert has gone on the record of
saying that writing is about the story
to be honest that's what frank herbert
did
he's getting across the information
effectively
it's honestly incredible another writer
that this reminds me of honestly is
brandon sanderson i think frank herbert
is even better than sanderson at this
just in that first paragraph with the
reverend mother we learn
that they are on the atretes family
holding we know that this is a very
wealthy
family she is old she's feeling her
age in the morning we learned that the
benny jesuit
hate the spicing guild and we also
learned that paul
is just an important person no one can
deny him because he is
so important why is he important that'll
be answered later but it's important for
us to know that he is important there's
a line break and a separate paragraph we
learn
a piece of information that really puts
the plot forward because
if paul had been born a girl the story
would have played out much much
much differently control of information
and that
is herbert's focus because there is a
type of beauty in that i think
the third part of frank herbert's style
i would like to point out
is that he uses effective descriptive
language
when it is absolutely necessary when
herbert uses
visual imagery it's often striking and
character focused it's uncluttered
it's clear i imagine having too much
descriptive language
would clutter up the page would make it
harder to discern what is happening
frank herbert was a journalist right
visual auditory details come only when
they
absolutely serve a purpose so at the end
of the page we get a description of paul
like we have never seen before
she just studies him in one gestalt and
flicker i always like that phrase his
face is oval
and black black hair the thin disdainful
nose and green eyes already we can
picture this person we need so few
pieces of detail about what he looks
like
he has a nose that is disdainful which
kind of pompous you know he's a wealthy
person
born into privilege you know in summary
frank herbert i believe
is a really excellent writer because i
think a lot of people just
think oh well he uses awkward words kind
of jargon you know because
there's a lot of jargon and because
frank herbert's more focused on
clarity of information people get this
idea that he's
bad or not not a good writer he's an
extremely effective clear writer
he needs to be appreciated more on just
a line by line level
looking at him line by line it's really
wonderful what he can get across and
there's so much that can be learned
especially if you're a science fiction
fantasy writer or any writer at all
there's so much that can be learned and
appreciated and enjoyed by
looking at his writing line by line and
i wish more people more critics and
readers were focused on doing that
because we get the ideas
we get the big picture we get what he
was trying to say the symbols the story
the science the religion the philosophy
all these things are yes wonderful and
should be studied but the line by line
stuff
that's what keeps a person reading at
the end of the day we wouldn't still be
reading the book if it was just all
about ideas and whatever people say oh
just read it for the ideas and stuff but
at the end of the day it was about it
was just about the ideas if the language
was
not worthy of any of the ideas nobody
would be reading it nobody would care to
get to the ideas i think it's a bit
snobby
snobbish to be looking down at his
writing style when
it's so wonderfully conveys what he's
trying to the story his
story he was trying to tell so this
analysis turned into a bit
of a rant as i tend to do that's okay
yeah let me know if this kind of video
is interesting to you
if if you want to see more more videos
like this i can i can cover
you know a lot of different different
writers and um like and subscribe if
you're new here
yeah let me know what you think if if
you um haven't read
dune maybe this will make you want to
read it who knows and
if you have read it was herbert's style
a hindrance to you enjoying it or did it
help add to the story let me know
and i hope everybody has a pleasant
day